♪ ♪
>> Greg: SATURDAY THE TIMES
PUBLISHED A PIECE THAT HIT TRUMP
FOR NOT BEING QUICK TO RESPOND
TO THE VIRUS.
WRITTEN BY SIX JOURNALISTS, ALL
WHO COULD HAVE OR SHOULD HAVE
DONE SOMETHING SOONER, BUT IN
IT.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO KEEP SAYING
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING SOONER NEVER SAY THAT
TO THE GUILTY PARTY, LIKE THE
TIMES ITSELF WHO TWEETED THIS ON
JANUARY 9TH "THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT THE VIRUS, THE
CORONAVIRUS IS READILY SPREAD BY
HUMANS, AND IT HAS NOT BEEN TIED
TO ANY DEATHS, DOUBLE HOOPS.
BUT HEALTH OFFICIALS IN CHINA
INTERNATIONALLY ARE WATCHING IT
CAREFULLY.
SO NOT ONLY DID THEY DISMISS THE
VIRUS, BUT ALSO TRUSTED CHINA
WOULD HANDLE IT.
AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO LISTEN TO
THE TIMES?
IF TRUMP HAD DONE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE, THE PRESS WOULD HAVE
SCREAMED "AUTOCRAT," BECAUSE
THAT’S WHAT THEY WERE SCREAMING
ALREADY.
THEY CALLED THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS RACIST, AND ACCUSE
THE TASK FORCE OF NOT BEING
DIVERSE, AS IF VIRUSES HAVE AN
HR DEPARTMENT.
THE ONLY CRISIS THE TIMES COULD
REPORT ON WAS THAT TRUMP’S
PRESIDENT.
AND ABOUT THE ACTING TOO SLOW
SLOW B.S., THE ECONOMY KEEPS THE
WORLD AFLOAT.
I HOPE WE EXAMINE THE EFFECTS OF
A SHUT DOWN BEFORE WE PULLED THE
TRIGGER.
IF YOU DID AND IT’S COMING
YOU’RE AN IDIOT OR A "TIMES"
EDITOR.
SO WE COULD HAVE DONE IT SOONER,
BECAUSE EVERYTHING GOOD COULD BE
DONE SOONER, BUT THE PEOPLE
SAYING IT NOW COULD NOT BE
BOTHERED THEN.
I CAN SHOW YOU HOW UP IN THE
FEBRUARY, THE VIRUS DID NOT
REALLY EXCITE THE MEDIA AT ALL.
THEY WERE NECK-DEEP IN THE
IMPEACHMENT SANDBOX.
AND NOW THEY ARE TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY.
WHY IS THAT?
DO WE REALLY NEED TO ASK?
THE IMPEACHMENT FAILED, SO LET’S
TRY THIS.
SO, BRET, THERE WAS SOME NEWS
TODAY THAT TRUMP RETWEETED A
TWEET CALLING FOR FAUCI TO BE
FIRED.
WHEN THAT CREATED A LITTLE DUST
UP, THE WHITE HOUSE BLASTED THE
IDEA OF FIRING FAUCI AS
RIDICULOUS, HE WOULD NOT FIRE
HIM, THEY GET ALONG GREAT, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU MR. BAIER
IF YOU CARE TO ANSWER IT.
I LOVE HOW THE MEDIUM HAS TRIED
TO CREATE A SCHISM BETWEEN FAUCI
AND TRUMP.
AND WHEN IT APPEARS THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME CONFLICT, THEY
PANIC.
THERE IS A SCHISM THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO CREATE FOR TWO
MONTHS.
>> Bret: IT’S PRETTY AMAZING
WATCHING THE STORY.
IT GOES UP LIKE A ROLLER COASTER
AND THEN DOWN.
WAIT A SECOND, FAUCI IS NOT AT
THE BRIEFING.
WHERE IS HE?
AND THEN DOWN, TRUMP SAYS I
TRUST HIM AND I WANT TO LISTEN
TO EVERYTHING HE SAYS.
THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TODAY, I THINK.
HE WILL PROBABLY BE ASKED TO THE
SAME THING AT AT THE BRIEFING
TODAY.
READ TWEETING THAT SAYS FIRE
FAUCI AT THE END, IS THAT
ADVISABLE?
NO.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE QUICKLY CAME
OUT AND SAID THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO FIRE HIM.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS PUSHING
BACK ON REALLY BEING ATTACKED
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND HE RETWEETED SOMETHING THAT
SHOWED THAT FAUCI AT THE END
OF JANUARY SAID THAT THE VIRUS
WAS NOT GOING TO BE A THREAT TO
AMERICANS, OR WAS A LOW THREAT
AT BEST.
TO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE IS A
LOT OF BLAME TO GO AROUND SAID
WHAT AT THE BEGINNING.
THE BIGGEST BLAME SHOULD BE
CHINA.
WHAT THEY DID AND DID NOT DO AND
WHAT THEY ALSO DIDN’T TELL THE
WORLD ABOUT HOW CONTAGIOUS THIS
DISEASE WAS.
>> Bret: I AGREE.
JUAN, WOULD YOU AGREE?
YES, I’M SURE YOU WOULD PRAY TO
THAT THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS OF
BILL CLINTON TOOK OUR EYE OFF
THE BALL OF AL QAEDA AND RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERROR THAT GAVE US
9/11, AND ONE COULD MAKE THE
SAME EXTENSION TO THIS
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE THAT TOOK US
THE EYE OFF OF THE BALL OF THE
CORONAVIRUS?
>> Juan: NO, I DON’T THINK
THAT.
I THINK THE MEDIA EYE, IF THAT’S
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT WAS IN THE HEADLINES, BUT
THE PRESIDENT IS THE PRESIDENT.
HE GETS INFORMATION THAT NOBODY
ELSE GETS.
AND WHAT WE KNOW FROM "TIMES"
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING,
AP REPORTING IS THAT HE WAS
WARNED SEVERAL TIMES BY EVEN
MICK MULVANEY WHO WAS THEN CHIEF
OF STAFF AND NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL, PETER NAVARRO, THE
ECONOMIC ADVISER.
ALEX AZAR, HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY.
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID WAS
DOWNPLAY A LOT OF THESE
WARNINGS.
IN FACT, WHEN THE WOMAN WHO
HANDLES RESPIRATORY AND
IMMUNIZATION SAID SOMETHING
WITHOUT HIS ACKNOWLEDGMENT, HE
BASICALLY SAID, THESE PEOPLE ARE
ALARMIST, BECAUSE IT IS SPOOKING
THE STOCK MARKET.
I JUST THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY THE PRESIDENT HAS SOME
RESPONSIBILITY THERE.
DOES THE PRESS?
I LIKE WHAT YOU READ ABOUT THE
"TIMES" BECAUSE IT IS A
REMINDER.
LOTS OF PEOPLE WERE SLOW TO COME
TO THIS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OR THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE.
AND THEY HAVE INFORMATION AT A
DIFFERENT LEVEL.
THAT’S WHY WHEN DR. FAUCI WAS
ASKED THIS QUESTION YESTERDAY ON
TELEVISION, HE SAID, YES, IF WE
WOULD HAVE ACTED MORE QUICKLY,
LIVES COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED.
I LIKE TO LOOK FORWARD AND SAY,
LET’S COME TOGETHER.
AND I DON’T THINK YOU CAN EXCUSE
THE FACT THAT WE WERE SO SLOW TO
ACT.
AND THE PRESIDENT WAS MUCH MORE
INVESTED IN WHAT HE CALLS BEING
A CHEERLEADER FOR A NATION THEN
SPEAKING TO THE THREAT.
IT WAS A VERY VISIBLE THREAT
BEING POSED BY THE CORONAVIRUS
IS.
>> Greg: JUAN BRINGS UP
DR. FAUCI WHO WAS TELLING PEOPLE
EMERGE THAT THEY COULD GO ON
CRUISES.
SO I THINK IN THE MIND OF TRUMP
AND EXPERTS, THERE WAS A VALUE
TO KEEP THE PANIC AT BAY WHILE
THEY TOOK, CAME TO GRIPS WITH
THIS AND DISCUSS THE BIG
DECISIONS ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
THE VIRUS.
IT WAS NOT A DENIAL PHASE, IT
WAS WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH INCOMING INFORMATION
WHERE YOU WOULD ADJUST YOUR
STANCE AS THE INFORMATION
CHANGED.
YOU ARE NOT TRYING TO PULL THE
WOOL OVER ANYBODY’S EYES, YOU
WERE TRYING TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY, DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> Jesse: I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT.
AND I WOULD ALSO AGREE WITH BRET
THAT IT ALL FALLS ON CHINA.
JUAN AND THE REST OF THE MEDIA
ARE COMPARING DONALD TRUMP TO
PERFECTION.
HE IS NOT PERFECT, HE IS NOT
CLOSE TO PERFECT EITHER.
LOOK AT WHAT THE MEDIA’S PERFECT
SCENARIO WOULD HAVE BEEN?
THEY WOULD HAVE SAID,
DONALD TRUMP IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SENATE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL SHOULD
HAVE SENT TO THE SENATOR’S HOME
TO THEIR DISTRICTS TO SHELTER IN
PLACE.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE TOLD ALL
THE BOATERS OF THE COUNTRY,
DON’T GO TO THE POLLS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA ON SUPER TUESDAY,
STAY HOME AND SHELTER IN PLACE?
HE WOULD HAVE SAID IN FEBRUARY
BEFORE ONE PERSON DIED.
REMEMBER, FIRST DEATH MARCH 1ST,
DON’T GO TO EASTER CHURCH
SERVICES.
YOU WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO GO.
COULD YOU GIVE HER IMAGINE THE
REACTION IF DONALD TRUMP WOULD
HAVE DONE THAT IN FEBRUARY?
YOU CAN SEE THE HEADLINE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RIGHT NOW.
AMERICAN DESPOTISM.
RIGHT?
AND DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE
TWEETED "FAKE NEWS" AND WE WILL
ALL WOULD HAVE HAD A BIG LAUGH.
BUT THE TRAVEL BAN CAME AT THE
END OF JANUARY PRAYED AND THE
FULL ECONOMIC SHUTDOWN CAME
MID-MARCH.
THAT WAS SIX WEEKS.
SIX WEEKS WENT BY LIKE THAT.
IF YOU ASKED ME, IT WAS PRETTY
FAST.
IT WAS NOT LIKE THIS WHOLE TIME
IN SIX WEEKS JOE BIDEN, JUAN,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," EVERY
SCIENTIST IN THE COUNTRY WERE
SCREAMING AT TRUMP, SHUT THE
ECONOMY DOWN, MAN, SHUT IT DOWN.
NO, THEY WEREN’T SAYING ANYTHING
THE WHOLE MONTH OF FEBRUARY THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT MANY MIKE AND
WHETHER HE NEEDED A PLATFORM TO
STAND ON AND DEBATE.
THAT WAS NOT IN THE COUNTRY’S
HEAD.
SO TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT THIS
AND SAY, OH, WOULD’VE, COULD’VE,
SHOULD’VE, THESE ARE
JOHNNY-COME-LATELY IS.
>> Greg: IT IS FUNNY WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE WERE
CONSUMED WITH.
AND I THINK THAT FOR SOME REASON
THE MEDIA CAN ONLY JUGGLE ONE
BALL AT A TIME.
AND IT IS A BALL THAT HARMS
THEIR ADVERSARY.
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
ALL THOSE DAYS THAT I SAT NEXT
TO MY COLLEAGUES,
ANDY McCARTHY,
MARTHA MacCALLUM, FOR
LITERALLY HOURS.
AND BRET WAS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WITH
CHRIS WALLACE, AND WE SAT THERE
AND I COULD JUST FEEL MY REAR
END GETTING WIDER AS WE SAT
THERE FOR HOURS AND HOURS.
I REMEMBER SAYING, IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO COVER THIS CHINA STORY
IF WE COULD EVER GET TO IT.
BUT YOU HAVE TALKED BEFORE ABOUT
HOW PROTECTIVE AMERICA FEELS
BECAUSE THE OCEANS ON EITHER
COAST, AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
PRETTY GOOD NEIGHBORS, AND SO
THREATS LIKE THIS DON’T REALLY
MATERIALIZE FOR A WHILE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY IS
I HAVE BEEN A PART OF A LOT OF
LOOK-BACK STORIES.
HURRICANE KATRINA, THE 9/11
COMMISSION REPORT, ENHANCEMENT
VERIFICATION, THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS, THOSE ARE STORIES WHERE
HINDSIGHT IS 20/20.
THEY HAVE THAT SAYING FOR A
REASON.
YOU CAN CONNECT ALL THE DOTS
VERY EASILY IF YOU SAY, HERE,
YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY LOOK AND SEE
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN YOU ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF SOMETHING COMING YOU
ARE DEALING WITH THE INFORMATION
YOU HAVE AT THAT TIME.
MAYBE YOU MAKE THE WRONG CALL,
BUT YOU TRY TO DO BETTER.
ONE THING THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM NEEDS TO
THINK ABOUT GOING FORWARD IS
THAT IS ONE STORY, THE LOOK
BACK.
THE LOOK AHEAD AND WHAT THE
COUNTRY WILL GO THROUGH
ECONOMICALLY AND POSSIBLY
HEALTHWISE, THOSE STORIES ARE
GOING TO BE EVEN HARDER TO DO.
SO THEY NEED TO BE ON TOP OF
THIS.
LAST THING, I’M SORRY, I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THIS ABOUT
DR. FAUCI.
THIS WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE HAS MOSTLY BEEN
AVAILABLE TO ANY OUTLET THAT
ASKS, AND THEY ARE TRYING TO GET
THE PUBLIC INFORMATION OUT
THERE.
IF YOU ARE A JOURNALIST THAT IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
DRIVE THE WEDGE BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND FAUCI SO THAT YOU
CAN FEATHER YOUR OWN NEST AND
THEN WORRY THAT OH, MY GOSH, THE
PRESIDENT MIGHT FIRE DR. FAUCI,
BUT THAT’S WHAT YOU ARE SEEKING
COMING YOU SHOULD REALLY RETHINK
THAT.
BECAUSE DR. FAUCI IS BEING AS
RIGHT AS HE CAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LISTENING TO
HIM AND BEING GRACIOUS AS WELL.
MY LAST POINT IS, YES, THEY DID
SEND OUT A STATEMENT SAYING THE
MEDIA IS BEING RIDICULOUS, WE
NEVER WOULD’VE FIRED FAUCI.
IT WAS NOT THAT QUICK.
IT WAS A FULL 18 HOURS BEFORE
THEY DID THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
FASTER IF THAT’S WHAT THEY MEAN.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU MAKE A
MISTAKE, EVERYBODY MAKES
MISTAKES IN THE FOG OF WAR, IT
IS CORRECTING THEM QUICKLY THAT